guys of the kind of caliber that you're
looking for you're looking for
conservative guys that are ambitious you
know reasonably good-look empathetic
honest uh they got strong energy they're
ambitious not you know like all these
sorts of things that you're mentioned
like all women are generally competing
for like the top 20% of guys out there
right like given the choice between a
tall uh physically strong like angular
jaw successful competent
influential uh guy and like an Average
Joe you're almost always going to take
the better looking dude it's just it's
in women's genetic programming like in
your DNA like if you pair bond with a
loser 2,000 years ago it could have
spelled certain death for you and your
children right so making Intelligent
Decisions when it comes to dating guys
and inviting them into your life and
being intimate with them like you've got
like you made the point that you got to
be careful with it though right because
you don't want to deal with crazy or get
kidnapped or duct taped to a bowling
ball or whatever that dude was all about
um the point that I'm making though is
there's a lot of dudes out there that
have their [__] together and they don't
have time to basically [__] around and
be like well if I don't do this then
she's not going to date me because
they've got so much abundance in their
phone they'll just go to the next girl
that will you know confirm the date with
them and agree to meet them uh for an
hour for a drink or for a coffee and
maybe a stroll in a park somewhere in a
public park where there's a lot of
people like nothing I'm not saying take
him in the woods like [__] Hansel and
gredle and stuff like that um but these
guys don't generally have a lot of time
to [__] around and like oh I've got
three hours and I got to get dressed up
and have dinner and she could suck like
one of the problems that guys run into
from the mail perspective is you could
be sitting down at dinner wasting two or
three hours of your evening on somebody
that doesn't look anything like their
pictures like they've been fat fished or
something like that um has the personal
ity of like a
pencil and has misled or lied about
certain things about what she's all
about because I mean both men and women
lie right like men will deceive women in
what areas usually about height and
success and influence would you
say uh yeah I've been catfish several
times before actually it's common that's
that's why I do my best to filter out
before what you us get like the guy will
say that he's six foot tall and you meet
him and you're like no that called not
on that because I have laser
I've called a guy out I'm like you're 5
fo 11 okay I can see so what's your
height requirement for you he got to be
over six foot there's no requirement
it's just um I'll take the guy who's
honest about his height over the one
who's saying they're 6 foot zero when
they're really 511 or 510 how tall are
you I
just five foot zero okay so you're five
foot tall would you go out with a guy
that's like 5 foot three like if he was
honest in his dating profile and said
I'm 5 foot three
I I have gone out with a short guy not
that short but uh yeah but he had a
shitty personality so okay I don't
discriminate against height I do prefer
taller men but it's not a
requirement isn't men isn't that
interesting that women don't
discriminate against height but they
have a preference for
height are you unplugging and seeing the
code in The Matrix here boys um anyway
so back to the point of the male
perspective so a lot of these super
successful guys that are doing cool [__]
that are the kind of guys that you want
to go out with they might be the kind of
guy that be like hey P um 8 o'clock
Thursday wear the black dress in picture
three I'll meet you at this place we'll
go for a coffee I've only got about an
hour because I'm super busy that night
meet me then you good to go or is it
yeah I'd probably say yes if he if he
meets the requirements of like a decent
human being then sure yeah but I mean
you really can't tell if he's a decent
human being until you meet him right
it's like you're more or less making
that decision based on a few photographs
some [__] bio that exists a couple
of exchanges back and forth like he's
not weird he didn't send you a dickpick
immediately he's not saying like he's
going to tape you to a bowling ball like
he's reasonably calibrated as a guy and
says hey you know let's go out this
night this time wear this and I'll see
you then like that's a
reasonable situation for you to say
Absolutely I'll see you there looking
forward to
it yeah Bri what about
you I'm yeah
find by me is that preferable for you
like would you like the guy just to take
the lead and be like hey let's get off
the app give me your number we're going
to set the date even go to the point to
say I really like what you're wearing in
pictures three wear that black thing
I'll see you there at 8 o'clock yes
here's a here's a link to the Google Map
you know for that place because you're
not familiar with it right like he like
he takes care of all of these things
like that's preferable yes uh P Yes
except for the telling me what toar we
thing depending on the day I might be a
little
sassy Lynn you're free to join the cast
if you want yeah she came in last week
she wouldn't join but let's see if she
has the GU oh that's right see I'm gonna
tell you right now that's [__]
because when I was single I would tell
women what to wear and they would do
it that's about having frame in the
relationship guys and that's the
difference between what's said and
what's actually done
um I think personally women want to hold
out this independent image to the public
where they don't need no man and they
can do it all themselves and they got it
but at the same time they also want to
be led by a guy am I right or wrong you
guys tell
me um I don't try to put out that image
of myself but I do agree with you for
most women I think I'm very open about
no I expect to have like an assertive
man that's what I want like tell me what
you want and bring out the subm missive
energy and I'm fine with people knowing
that about me what about you
P
um yeah I would say so but like again if
I'm in a mood or something I might get
sassy about what to wear especially
easier on you doesn't it make it easier
like if every decision is made for you
before the date all you have to do is
show up on time look ready to have fun
like if I'm having an out cres or mal
fun or
something think of every possible
scenario but um but I mean even in
general like even if somebody was like
hey I like that you should wear that
like yeah it's easier it's easier less
trustful I don't have to think about
things I can take extra time to do other
things so yeah yeah like that's my point
and guys are incredibly bad at trying to
lead a woman in that direction they've
been told their entire life that you
know men and women are equal um you know
women have been oppressed so stop
oppressing them become less they can
become more a lot of these narratives um
the the notion of toxic feminism I don't
think serves women certainly doesn't
serve men it doesn't serve the
relationship in the direction of what
builds uh women to be a compliment to a
guy's life and a man to complement her
life and you know be useful and preside
and protect and those sorts of things I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and Pinn Down Below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out